a particular is on a horizontal line so
it's displacement X centimeters there's
my first unit to the right of the origin
so now I have an orientation at time T
seconds there's my second unit is x
equals that okay so I'm just going to
drop a few of those things down first so
i'm going to say x displacement is in
centimeters time is in seconds and x+ is
to the right okay so now let's just much
there a lot of this just starts off
fairly simply write it says parte
differentiate to find V and X double dot
as functions of time I don't know why
they're mixed up x dots and double dots
and b's and a's but we're just wrong
again okay they all are equivalents and
when I want to fly a velocity boss is
just the first 3 V 4 u.just back to time
so can you tell me what it is can you
read it off
perfect okay there's a first derivative
to get acceleration which they're just
you just X double dot so I'm just going
to use the invitation I need to
differentiate what velocity who said
volume velocity with respect to time
okay so differentiate again which gives
me excellent so this is not complicated
again just like in rates of change and
access your growth UK the emphasis here
is not on crazy fancy things to
differentiate or integrate once we get
to integration it's about do can you
interpret what's going on and therefore
differentiate their I think an
interpreter at their puppet where's the
particle initially and what are its
speed and acceleration okay so whenever
you hear the word initially that means
what T equals 0 T equals 0 so I'm going
to say when T equals 0 and I'll just get
a march through one at a time right so
the question of where is it that's what
it says first where is the particle
initially have a look it's just that x
equals 2 right so I would actually say x
equals 2 but what that means is like the
adds to the question is I am two
centimeters to the right of the origin
yeah okay um then they want varsity and
they want acceleration so v is equal to
then form so what does that mean again
I'm temporary everything every number
hasn't me so the first thing is on the
units are one centimeter per second
which direction I going to to the left
that's where I'm moving right now okay
at the first instant and then lastly
here it is here's X double dot so my
acceleration is equal to
negative 12 so that means now is
interesting right I haven't really
addressed this yet this is this idea of
I'll directionless stuff so we call this
by the way the fancy word for this is a
scalar okay this has direction involved
speed versus varsity so we call this a
vector it has direction okay when you
have a look at all of these things the
units come along for the ride so for
instance if this in centimeters and this
is centimeters per second because your
differentiate with respect to time once
your differentiated with respect to time
another time here right so instead of
what i got here are 12 centimeters per
second it's all cities per second per
second I'm thinking about how the
velocity of energy so you can either say
per second per second you actually can
say that or you can take per second
sweat right because that's on the
denominator or even child Santa me sorry
yeah 1270 is per second to the negative
2 they all mean the same thing right and
this is just using a negative index to
replace the division which way is it
going it's also to the left okay so I
don't want to think about getting faster
getting star I don't want to think about
the word deceleration is just confusing
okay I just want to think that is
velocity changing and if so how much I'd
in what direction okay so there is this
this at time zero right at time zero is
the velocity and it is changing the next
instant in time T equals 0.000001 the
voice is not going to be that anymore so
the velocity is changing and this is
what it's changing by look at them look
at the sign look at the sign right this
is telling you the direction that the
displacement or the velocity or the
acceleration is facing right so let's
actually let's progress and hopefully
we'll make
centrally interpret these numbers okay
it says our party at time T equals three
and then they asked a series of
questions so let's break this apart by
the way it's a bit funny they sit at
time T equals 3 you'll notice I've said
when time T equals e because it's a time
so it doesn't matter i mean what they
mean is like at t equals 3 they're just
you know interpreting a value but i'm
just going to use the word that means
time they want to know is the particle
left or right at the origin okay so for
starters what am I going to do to find
out whether I'm left or right of the re
i'm just going to evaluate displacement
at that time right so when t plus 3x is
equal to okay let's see 27 take away 6
times 9 which is 54 take away 3 plus 2
did I do it right yeah I really should
get a number out of this that's needed
to be 730 new year 28 yeah so can I
answer the question it's to the left
they just want to which side I was on
part two so I was probably part two is
he traveling to the left or to the right
okay so when I say easy traveling which
of these quantities are my interested in
Boston very good sir I'm going to
continue with my equals three here's my
velocity function so i'm going to say V
equals right guys 27 take away 6 1
that's going to be negative 10 so this
is did they ask direction or do they ask
for magnitude easier traveling they just
want a direction is it traveling left or
right
okay okay last one part 3 pretty sure
its acceleration right they want to the
direction of acceleration okay so a is
equal to and I'm going to valuate it
there it is that's 18 take 112 I don't
think so yeah so sorry let's just that's
a great question by the way accelerator
look not confident some issues not
concert accelerating is changing
depending on what your time is right so
for instance remember when I rubbed it
off unfortunately remember when I took
that graph and I said okay what would
happen if there was no acceleration and
what would happen to the graph at that
time it would just become a trail and go
off at its current velocity okay there's
a specific moment in time where there's
no acceleration acting on this object
right when is it at time to write it's
no longer accelerating to the left it
stops accelerating for a moment right
and then as you can see what happened in
this is equal to the sign of which is
positive so therefore it's accelerating
to your mind okay so you see these
equations they give you a road map for
what this thing is doing right it's
accelerating it starts off accelerate to
the left at some point in time which we
just answered it stops accelerating and
then if you keep on progressing it
starts accelerating inning or pursuit
direction to the right okay girls Part C
Part D when is it part of acceleration 0
we just answered that question it was
timing i should say a equals 0 when x
equals 2 and they asked us for a
velocity at that point right what is it
for speed once the speed now since speed
doesn't care about direction right we're
going to get a velocity out and then
we're just not going to worry about
which direction is facing what is the
Boston with time 15 is nothing yes so
we're getting a three times this is 12
take away 24 take away one which is
negative 30 that's the velocity
therefore
speed is just 13 because I don't worry
about the direction of the positive
negative what my units against
centimeters per second now even though
they don't ask us to do this we can
graph please I love to understand this
better and a simple even it's not
beautiful all the information we've got
at the moment will draw a picture for us
and then we can understand a whole lot
better let's not worry about that okay I
just want to get a rough sketch I mean
they didn't even ask me any for this
question okay by the way just as a point
up one of the reasons why they didn't
ask you is because if the stationary
points and all these kind of things are
nice and neat um then you won't get nice
and ignorance they'll be irrational
disaster so let's think out just what I
know okay initial conditions where are
mine and then x equals 2 i'm just going
to put that there ok this is in the
positive direction here's my x axis
using the time axis and which way am I
going well I'm going down in the
negative direction and I'm also getting
faster and faster now what does that
mean am I concave up or concave down I'm
concave down I mean acceleration is the
second derivative which is concavity and
this is concave down so therefore it's
doing something like that right it's
dropping like a rock okay um what else
did you say this is teak was three more
about that yet when T equals two we
already worked out the velocity now
acceleration stops at that one so
imagine what's happening let me
accelerating the negative direction I'm
accelerating accelerating after two
seconds the acceleration let's call that
tune stops it stops and we know from
this earlier part of the question the
acceleration actually turns around it
starts pushing that way right so what
happens at this instant there is no
concavity so back in curve sketching
when we call that a point of inflection
point inflection beans can cavity
changing down to up right so is
that's doing this okay does that make
sense now because this is a qubit I'm
expecting that I'm guessing to something
like this and something like this that's
what a cubic does okay you can go ahead
and you can grab this and find out I'm
not interested in what this points are
I'm just interested in describing the
behavior of this thing based on all this
stuff that I go okay now by the way this
is important for me because that's the
steepest part here don't you see that
before this Armada steep in the New Year
version and after the mall so nervous
state so the interpretation for that
speed equals 1370 s per second
interpretation is that's the fastest i
get within this time here obviously i
get faster as i go to time infinity but
maybe that is that part of the domain is
not relevant to me I'm just interested
in this little area here okay so it's
the fastest thing I'm moving not
worrying about direction does that make
sense I can keep asking questions I
could ask like when you stop at what
point are you stationery how would I do
that I 5 volts 20 equals 0 because that
is the stationary point after all yeah
exactly because I'm going to have
another obsession to point over here but
I'm not interested in that one or really
interested in time zero I could ask
things like how long does it take me to
pass the origin in their return I can
work that out you could do average speed
original speed etc okay